talking about the Infinity Ward trailer
and for the sake of cred got spider-man
embouchure because that's how cred works
it's YouTube people but we have
ourselves a new and probably final
trailer for Avengers infinity Wars
should be the final trailer anyway movie
comes out like a month there should be
no more trailers probably a little bit
up because Studios love doing that
I haven't called these videos trailer
reviews how do you review a trailer it's
just kind of my thoughts but no one
searches Avengers infinity war trailer
thoughts so review it is whatever this
trailer starts out with Gamora talking
she's like I've known this guy for a
while we see that she has we always knew
that she had but then you see bring your
daughter to the apocalypse day oh so
cute she's like if it gets all the
stones his galactic scale apocalypse
just like that like snapping his fingers
which means we'll never see him get all
the stones cuz they're to be over unless
he gets all the stones and then
monologues like now the day has come no
I'm not gonna end everything yet I'm a
villain gonna monologue I'd be dumb they
really dick us over like they're really
Punk us he gets all the stones for the
ultimate power then a chest is just like
a bunch of scrolls and books appears in
front of him he's like oh it was
knowledge that's the most powerful force
in the universe
and we all just leave underwhelm it does
look like the Avengers as a whole get
some Wakanda TAC is that straight-up
looks like Wakanda tax because any
Avengers getting their balls kicked in
they retreat to what condo because if
there's one place on earth it can hide
from Thanos is probably the most hidden
place on earth so they probably go to
Wakanda than Charice like hey iron man
here's some new tech all right then we
got some iron man will con detect you go
iron man you go take out your space
donut but if it falls from the sky
remember to run from its sideways not
straight on like these morons I'm not
even gonna pretend to know who that
creep is giving Doctor Strange
acupuncture for sure I saw him in attack
of the clones maybe that's what happened
it's a whole interconnected universe and
Disney wins again you hear Tony Stark
say we have one advantage he's coming to
us we have what he wants so that's what
we're gonna use and it shows vision
because he does have that stone in his
hat yeah using him as bait I can respect
that when your amazon echo takes human
Foreman becomes the vision might as well
use it as bait this is my machines hate
us by the way selector like it really
does feel like in this movie it is going
down and I've said this before but you
know the first Avengers movie was cool
seeing everyone come together now
everybody's coming together which is
mind-blowing to seeing the trailers in
the first place but really the world is
ending I do like that one line Thanos
has it looks like he's talking to Iron
Man where he's like I hope they remember
you kind of shows he's not above those
sentimental moments that's why I love
these Marvel movies and looking forward
to this Avengers movie it's been a ten
year
jurnee a ten-year road stakes have been
getting higher and higher and higher
until these this is the stake these are
the stakes of stakes cinematically
speaking I like that it's very
unprecedented I'm glad I was here for
and the last shot I love the last shot
because he's like come here captain and
by Captain America so awesome Captain
America is like the America that America
wants to be and if there is one scene
one shot that can encompass the current
state of America it is that one right
there I do think in this movie a price
needs to be paid someone needs to die
not talking we think someone's dead and
now they're just paralyzed the hard
calls need to happen someone needs to
die it needs to be someone from the
phase one Avengers there's some
speculation because you don't see
Hawkeye really anywhere I think someone
else other than Hawkeye because if you
want to kill an Avenger and have the
least amount of collateral damage like
you know the acceptable loss of Avengers
would probably be Hawkeye in these
movies we need to someone else man
someone else needs to go down I don't
want to see it happen necessarily but I
just think it needs to and don't make it
at the beginning make it when it's
really going down maybe Hawkeye is at
the beginning like Johnny Cage in Mortal
Kombat annihilation is like I'll you
shut up you're next broken eyes they
recast before it's not even jeremy
renner james van der beek shows up to
get his neck broken at the beginning as
Hawkeye but this trailer is great it
showed me pretty much what I figured I
would see the next Avengers infinity war
trailer other than Fano showing up bad
things are happening it's I don't
nothing else about the movies so either
the movie is that or there's something
else going on and they're just keeping a
secret don't know that's where
speculation comes in I guess the
internet was the internet with that
speculation porn only and just slop horn
and who wants that okay yeah I do but
this new Avengers infinity war trailer
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]